okay welcome back everybody we have six
more lectures in the class both grades
we're getting pretty close to finishing
so today I'm going to tell you a little
bit more about Laplace transforms for
ordinary differential equations with
some kind of an external forcing and
some Wednesday we're going to look at
Laplace transforms for solving PDEs and
then after that that leaves four
lectures to talk about data methods
dimensionality reduction and a little
bit about numerical solutions to PD's so
it's just kind of a teeny you know
teaser at the end about about data stuff
okay so the last thing I told you last
time was about the frequency response so
if we had something like a spring mass
damper system and we have an ordinary
differential equation like X double dot
plus five X dot plus four x equals some
external forcing you and this has units
of acceleration or force then I have a
transfer function which essentially
tells me in the Laplace domain X hat X
bar my Laplace transform solution
divided by u bar is equal to one divided
by the characteristic polynomial so
that's s squared plus 5 s plus four one
over that and this is called my transfer
function big G of s okay this is just a
recap of last time so what I showed you
last time is that you can look at the
magnitude and the phase of this transfer
function and it tells you how this
system is going to react to sinusoidal
forcing at given frequencies okay so we
look at the magnitude and phase of this
transfer function at I Omega so we plug
in I Omega in for our Laplace variable s
and we look at the magnitude or the
phase and that tells me the magnitude in
the phase of this
so it'll output in response to
sinusoidal forcing so I'll just show you
a little MATLAB script a quick script
that allows us to compute this and I
just want to convince you that this
actually is in fact useful and what we
think it is okay so this is gonna be
pretty simple a simple simple script so
I'm gonna clear all close all CLC I'm
gonna make my transfer function which is
just a Laplace variable s and from that
Laplace variable s I'm gonna make my
system which is 1 divided by s squared
plus 5 s plus 4 I transfer function I
call this G if I really wanted to okay
and I'm going to look at my bode plot
figure bode of G this is just my
frequency response and I get a plot like
what we had before so we see that at low
frequencies for really low frequency x
axis is frequency we have you know a
constant amplitude sine wave output so
this is just constant at 0 phase meaning
it's exactly in phase with my forcing
and then as I force this thing faster
and faster the magnitude of my response
gets smaller and smaller and smaller and
it becomes exactly out of phase 180
degrees out of phase of my input this
magnitude is on a log scale in decibels
so like every you know so this is on a
logarithmic scale so minus 80 DB is a
really tiny number compared to minus 10
dB okay so what I can do now is what I'm
going to do first is I'm just going to
create a sine wave and run it through my
system see what it looks like so my time
is going to be a vector from 0.01 in
increments of 0.01 to 100 and U is going
to be sine of T I'm just going to input
a forcing at frequency
frequency 1 and Y is going to be el sim
of my system G given you given to you
did I show you else in last time yeah
okay good it's just a linear it
simulates the linear system with an
input u for time T and I'm going to plot
T by Y in black okay I get my bode plot
I get my sine wave it looks super choppy
maybe I messed up my DT probably did
yeah so it should be 0.1 and increments
to point 1 to 100 that looks better okay
so this is what the system actually does
in response to a pure tone sine wave and
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
use the information from my bode plot to
see if I can predict what that sine wave
is so I told you that the magnitude and
phase of GI Omega is going to be useful
so we're gonna see if we can actually
reconstruct that using just the transfer
function ok so what was my Omega what
was my frequency
just one alright one okay so my Laplace
variable is gonna be I times Omega and
then I'm going to plug in I'm gonna get
the magnitude okay how do I do this so
now I'm gonna say G of s is equal to so
I just redefined my Laplace variable s
so this is no longer an actual transfer
function S it's a number I Omega and so
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
recompute this expression where s is I
Omega and then I'm going to look at the
magnitude which is the absolute value of
G of s and my phase is going to be the
angle of G of s and I'm gonna hold my
plot on and I'm gonna plot time by my
magnitude times a sine wave of frequency
T plus phase in red okay does this make
sense what I'm doing here I'm just I'm
redefining my Laplace variable so it's
just I and I'm gonna plug that into my
transfer function this is just me
evaluating my transfer function at I at
s equals I I'm taking the magnitude and
the phase and I'm constructing a sine
wave with that magnitude and that phase
and T times Omega so maybe I should put
times Omega in here because if I change
Omega I want my frequency to change so
now when I plot that I get this red
dashed line and we see that we perfectly
get the magnitude and the phase and look
the magnitudes not one it's point you
know point one seven or something and
we're perfectly capturing the magnitude
and the phase of the sinusoidal response
just with two numbers from the from the
transfer function the magnitude and the
phase of G evaluated at I Omega does it
make sense okay so this is an extremely
powerful tool if I look at this transfer
function I can tell you what your system
is going to do to sinusoidal input of
any frequency I can tell you exactly
what its magnitude and phase of the
sinusoidal response is going to be super
useful a lot of information on one graph
okay any questions about this this is a
really important thing in control
systems and in mechanics and vibrations
and materials if you want to know where
your system might be sensitive to
instability or resonances because if you
see a sharp peak anywhere in this bode
diagram or this frequency response that
tells you that there's some input
frequency where if I force my system I
get a lot of response out I might even
get an amplification in the response and
that could cause system fatigue it could
cause failure so on a airplane wing I
would want to do the frequency response
of the actual wing to different you know
aerodynamic frequencies low frequency
turbulence high frequency turbulence and
I want to make sure that it doesn't have
any big resonant peaks that's gonna
cause the wing to be shaking or
vibrating because that'll essentially
cause fatigue and eventually failure
okay so you do this on essentially all
testing of materials where you think
that you want to have a long life and
there's going to be some vibrations
involved when I was a kid I lived near a
newspaper printing press and apparently
newspaper printing presses generate a
tremendous amount of vibrations at a
certain frequency they just shake
they'll shake the entire city block so
it's a printing press that's almost as
large as a city block and the whole
thing's shaking and they had to put the
entire printing press on top of a cork
platform to damp out a huge vibrational
mode so that it didn't shake everyone
within blocks of this printing press so
you can actively suppress different
frequencies if you want if you identify
them in this frequency response okay
good so we're going to be going back and
forth to MATLAB a little bit's today
okay good so this is the general idea I
have a physical system an ordinary
differential equation I can write down a
frequency transfer function in the
frequency domain by taking the Laplace
transform okay so now what I want to
talk to you a little bit about is the
impulse response so I've already alluded
to this impulse response which is
essentially what would happen if I give
my system and impulsive inputs okay so
the impulse response is essentially what
I would get if I gave my input you a
delta function so this is if you have t
equals a delta function of G now remind
me what are the properties of a delta
function integral is 1 yeah what is it
Delta look like itself
SuperDuper sharp like it's an infinitely
tall and skinny you know point like that
right it goes up to infinity but it has
infinitesimal width so it has exactly
area 1 under its curve and if I
integrate this so if I run this through
an integral then at exactly time T
equals zero my system goes from zero and
it steps up to one it integrates up that
unit area and my integral becomes one
okay so that's the property of my Delta
function what's another property of my
Delta function if I integrate some
function f of T by delta T at DT from
negative infinity to infinity
what do I know about this integral ok
it's just my function f evaluated at the
time where this Delta function is
nonzero because you can essentially say
this is f times zero everywhere except
time equals zero and then exactly at I
equals zero this thing integrates up to
so this is kind of like integral
negative infinity to infinity of f of
zero times my delta T because Delta T is
zero everywhere except for zero and then
this is f of zero integral and that just
equals F of zero so in general if I have
a function f of T and I integrate it
with a delta function t minus a so I'm
shifting this so that the Delta occurs
at some time a and this is going to
equal F a this is just a really useful
property of the Delta function I'm just
telling you this is gonna help on the
homework and I realize I probably didn't
mention this at all before okay so we're
gonna be using this Delta function
impulse response and we're going to
start thinking about what our system
power system responds to this Delta
function so the really cool thing about
a delta function is that even though it
has infinite magnitude
it occurs in an infinitesimal window and
so it only adds a finite amount of
energy to my system it doesn't make my
system blow up it's just like you know
taking my spring mass damper and hitting
it with a hammer
it might happen very very quickly it's
you know very high magnitude force but
it only adds a finite amount of energy
to the system okay so I'm gonna draw
some pictures and then we're gonna look
at what the impulse response actually
means okay so this is T equals zero this
is my response X again T equals zero so
my impulse response function is the
super ridiculously sharp thing that goes
up to infinity I could get this a number
of ways I could take little rectangles
and make them thinner and taller at the
same time I could take gaussians and
make the variance go to zero that would
all be fine
and what my system is going to do when I
give it this kick it's going to have
some response so it's not going to
respond for time less than zero because
it didn't have any inputs there's no
initial conditions and then at time
equals zero the system is going to do
something but eventually it's going to
die out because it stops getting input
this little diode if it's stable right
if all my eigen values are negative real
part okay so my impulse response is this
response to a unit impulse in you
now a couple of other things if we have
an eau de so for an eau de we have a
transfer function so for every linear OD
we can get its transfer function G of s
we just Laplace transform one divided by
the characteristic polynomial and so in
the frequency domain I say X bar equals
G bar times u bar this is my frequency
domain expression for my solution and if
I give this thing a unit impulse then
this is the same as G bar times one so
I'm using a fact here that the Laplace
transform of a delta function is just 1
okay so if Mayu is a delta function then
this is just G of s times one and I'm
going to call this X sub Delta because
this is my impulse response so now if I
want to find my solution X sub Delta of
time that's this thing here my response
given a delta function X sub Delta is
just my impulse response that's just
equal to the inverse Laplace transform
of G of s so what this means is that my
impulse response the response of my
system in the time domain to an
impulsive input is exactly equal to the
inverse Laplace transform of my transfer
function this is a pretty cool property
this is a very important relationship
they're like siblings or cousins okay so
this is super important I'm going to box
it the impulse response is the inverse
Laplace transform of the transfer
function and vice versa okay so there's
a really simple example we can use to
kind of visualize what's happening with
the with this impulse response so let's
say we have a simple linear OD e like X
dot equals you know X dot minus lambda x
equals equals U of T so this is just a
simple linear first-order OD with
forcing and let's say that I make this
you a delta function so I'm going to
look at the impulse response of this OEE
I'm gonna kick this ODU with some Delta
function forcing I'm gonna see what it
does
okay and we're going to assume zero
initial conditions usually when we do
impulse responses we're just looking at
the 0 initial condition case so let's
integrate both sides
okay so if I integrate X dot okay and
also we're thinking are we gonna
integrate like what are the bounds of
integration what are reasonable bounds
of integration for this system where do
we want to know its solution T greater
than or equal to zero right so we're
assuming for T less than zero nothing's
happening because there's no input we're
assuming exactly at T equals zero
there's this Delta function and then for
T greater than zero the system is
probably going to decay you know back
down to zero because it's a stable
system
maybe stable okay so I'm gonna just
integrate both sides for minus epsilon 2
epsilon 2 see what this Delta function
does right around times zero so let's
integrate X dot DT minus lambda times my
integral from minus epsilon 2 epsilon of
X of T DT equals my integral from minus
epsilon 2 epsilon of Delta of T DT ok so
each of these terms is super simple and
we can just evaluate it so what's the
integral of X dot with respect to T X of
ok so this is X evaluated at epsilon
minus X evaluated at minus epsilon minus
ok so X is basically 0 around this
entire time it's very very small and DT
is also very very small so this is this
is essentially like to epsilon times
something very small and we're going to
take epsilon going to 0 so I can say
that this is 0 I'm waving my hands but
you can convince yourself that this term
is 0 and this integral of my Delta
function is really easy to what's the
integral of Delta from minus epsilon 2
epsilon 1 this equals 1 ok what is X
evaluated at minus epsilon 0 because I
my system was at 0 initial condition for
all negative time so this is just saying
that X at time epsilon is equal to 1
and I could take this I'm making a very
crude argument this is basically equal
to 1 and X of epsilon in the limit as
epsilon goes to 0 plus you know equals 1
so this becomes exactly true as epsilon
goes to 0 what that means is that this
delta function at time 0 essentially
gives my system an initial condition of
1 at time 0 so this delta function is
just like an initial condition response
with X of 0 equals 1 and what is the
initial condition response of a stable
linear system just e to the lambda t
it's just decay either the lambda T I'm
assuming lambda is negative okay so
essentially what this Delta forcing does
is it establishes at you know positive
epsilon an initial condition for my
system and then the forcing goes away it
never comes back it was just a sharp
spike and then it was 0 after it gave my
system this initial condition for all
time after 0 it just looks like an
initial condition response ok so if you
were a detective and you came and we're
investigating this system at time
epsilon you couldn't tell the difference
between an impulse response and an
initial condition response
okay questions about this yeah sure so
we know that X is basically 0 for
negative time and we think X might be
nonzero for 0 to positive epsilon it's
going to be close to 1 but the integral
so this integral from negative epsilon 2
epsilon of X of T is actually going to
be about epsilon it's going to be about
1 the integral of 1 DT from zero to
Epsilon
I mean let me draw it so if i zoom in
from x 0 minus epsilon plus epsilon we
think our system is going to look like I
mean this thing's decaying but if i zoom
into epsilon its decaying really really
flute-like slowly so it might look like
that and so it starts off being 1 the
area under this curve is about epsilon
it's about epsilon times the height 1
maybe it's less than a slightly less
than epsilon but I'm gonna take the
limit as epsilon goes to 0 and so that
term is going to drop out yeah so yeah
you're absolutely right this is a little
bit crude but you can argue that this
should be 0 and it won't affect X
equaling 1 at that time infinitesimally
small okay good question other questions
about this impulse response yeah
actually it's different for higher order
systems so I'm showing you this just to
give you an intuitive feeling of four
simple simple systems and impulse
response looks like you just give it
some initial condition so we're kind of
adding to an initial condition what you
would really do in the homework for the
impulse response is you do it this way
you would take the Laplace transform of
your system you know you'd multiply it
by one and then you would in verse
Laplace transform your transfer function
and this inverse Laplace transform of
your transfer function will look like
something you know let's say that my
system was second-order like in the
spring mass system so this would be 1
divided by s squared plus 5 s plus 4 and
I could factor it into two terms those
in each be exponential terms and my
impulse response would be the sum of two
exponential terms and the coefficients
would be determined by the partial
fractions yeah so when you inverse
Laplace transform this thing you'll end
up getting cosines and sines movie with
a damping or a growth they'll get
something like e to the lambda T times
cosine I get to meet plus I have sine
Omega T and probably all the imaginary
stuff will cancel out okay okay good
questions other questions okay so this
is the card that was the cartoon now I'm
going to show you another more useful
cartoon did I tell you how to do the
impulse response in that lab just the
impulse command give impulse of G and
that lab has clever ways of
approximating this thing kind of
interesting you can actually find some
of the source code and figure out how
it's numerically doing these things
that's pretty pretty interesting okay so
the nice thing about the impulse
response is that it gives us an
intuition for how we solve these systems
with convolution okay so I'm showing you
the impulse response because I just want
you to be thinking about what little
kicks to my system does look like gives
me some initial condition response so we
know that our system we can solve
systems of
use with forcing using convolution so I
think I just shouldn't have erased that
but if I had you know x-bar equals G bar
u bar and I want to find out what is my
system X of T well that's equal to the
inverse Laplace transform of G bar
convolve with the inverse Laplace
transform of u bar what is the inverse
Laplace transform of u bar
it's just u of T it's my input if my
input in time
okay so times U of T now the inverse
Laplace transform of my transfer
function is this really special thing
called the impulse response inverse
Laplace transform of G of s is this
really special thing called the impulse
response okay it's a function of time
it's how my system rings after I kick it
and so this equals the integral from
minus infinity to infinity of my
function G of t minus tau U of tau D tau
that's just the definition of a
convolution integral I wanted to I could
have written it like minus infinity to
infinity of G of tau u of t minus tau
detail you can prove pretty easily that
you can you can do the t minus tau and
either argument you want doesn't matter
I like this one because it's much more
intuitive what we're doing and if I knew
that my forcing if I assumed zero
initial conditions and I assumed that
time started at zero then I can get rid
of this and just integrate from zero to
positive infinity if I want
okay so this is really useful we find
our solution in time is given by the
convolution of our impulse response with
our input you I kick so in in a real
practical system what I might do if I
wanted to know how my airplane wing is
going to respond so I told you that my
airplane wing might respond to low
frequencies and high frequencies and all
kinds of frequencies of turbulence but
I'm not in reality going to just get one
pure tone of turbulence I'm gonna get a
whole you know input U of T of
turbulence and so what I might do with
my wing is I might hit it with a hammer
measure its response and then take that
response and convolve it with my
turbulence input you
that's not sinusoidal it's whatever I
want it to be okay okay so now I'm going
to show you I want to tell you kind of
intuitively what convolution means
because I've been dancing around it but
it's really really important this
convolution integral how many of you
have read homework five or at least
glanced through it how many of you have
looked at the last problem okay so we're
gonna use this convolution integral to
simulate how sounds sound in a different
environment so one thing you can do is
you can take a recording of yourself
talking in an acoustically isolated room
so it's just your flat audio of exactly
how you sound it's different than how
you sound in your skull if you listen to
yourself playback on a tape recorder you
sound different so you can take that
sound U of T which is what you sound
like saying something and then you can
take the impulse response of a sound in
a concert hall or underwater or in a
long hallway or in a pool and this
impulse response of what you could do is
I could just put a microphone back where
one of you is sitting I could detonate a
small explosion right here or blast a
shotgun or something and record what you
hear in your microphone position I you
know excite a really big initial sound
and then you record it and you take that
signal and you can evolve it with any
other signal you want and what you'll
get is how that thing would
sound as if it was being played here and
listened to there okay so you can
simulate these are actually extremely
valuable these are worth real money you
can take the most expensive seats in a
concert hall and you can carefully
compute the impulse response in those
most expensive seats in a concert hall
and you can sell it to the record
companies and they do this they make
very expensive convolutions to simulate
how it sounds in the London Philharmonic
symphony hall okay yeah capturing all of
the interference and all of the objects
that are blocking the sound waves so if
when this sound is bouncing through the
room and bouncing off the tables and
that's the perfect sound because
everything is just so this is capturing
all of that and I'm being a little
careless here because the acoustic
equation in a three-dimensional Symphony
Hall is actually a partial differential
equation but these ideas definitely
generalized to solutions of partial
differential equations we'll talk about
that a little bit later okay so anyway
let's do another simple example of
convolution so our second simple example
is the following it's the exact same
simple example we're gonna look at X dot
plus lambda x equals U of T but maybe X
dot let's say X dot equals that's a
little bit better equals lambda X plus U
of T we're gonna have zero initial
conditions and I'm going to have a
function U of T which is just a square
wave pulse so I want to know what this
input does to this system using
convolution yeah
so this entire theory applies to linear
systems of OD ease and linear systems of
PD es there are an app analogues for
nonlinear systems but they're it's
complicated and it's messy and I don't
believe it so like there there are
really there are some good
generalizations they'll only really
trustworthy ones are so extensions to
non linear to nonlinear impulse
responses are called Volterra kernels
and this is actually largely developed
in the aerodynamics community to deal
with nonlinear vibrational problems
actually on wings go figure
so Volterra kernels are essentially more
and more G's that capture higher and
higher nonlinear non-linearity isn't
it's complicated but this is the only
mathematically satisfying extension that
doesn't seem like make-believe math to
me okay so how many of you have seen the
convolution integral illustrated in a
movie okay you're about to yeah okay so
we're gonna write a script in MATLAB
that's essentially going to go through
and compute the convolution integral as
tau goes through this system as T goes
through the system and we're gonna
figure out exactly what this input does
and exactly what convolution means kind
of intuitively okay so we have our input
maybe I'll just write down the math here
so the solution of this is X of T equals
the integral from minus infinity to
infinity of e to the lambda t minus tau
U of tau D tau you could get this any
number of ways we derived this in 564
last quarter
or you could take the Laplace transform
get the transfer function inverse
Laplace transform and do the convolution
by hand that's the same thing and this
of course is going to be the integral
from zero to infinity because we're
assuming that we have zero initial
conditions and that U is zero before
time to time T equals zero so this is
the solution and we're going to start
building up the solution by convolution
solution by convolution okay so we take
our system U and what we're essentially
doing is we're saying that every value
of U is like let me think of how to say
this so when u is not zero what I'm
going to do is I'm going to consider
this U as a continuous train of little
teeny tiny impulse responses I'm going
to say that this is a little impulse
response and its neighbors a little
impulse response and that's a little
impulse response and that's a little
impulse response and so on and so forth
so this is a train of infinitesimally
small impulse responses of
infinitesimally small impulse responses
what is the magnitude of this impulse
response this is a little infinitesimal
impulse response what's the area under
the curve no no that's the area of an
infinite impulse response what I'm
saying is that the area under this
little curve if this doesn't go up to
infinity it goes up to you so the area
is equal to U of tau D tau and D tau is
tiny so essentially what I'm what I'm
doing is I'm taking and saying that this
is like a delta function but it's got
instead of area one it's got area U of
tau D tau which this is effectively
infinitesimally details tiny but if I
add up enough of those details I get a
real area okay and every single one of
these little impulse responses gives me
an initial condition response with this
teeny tiny infinitesimal initial
condition and so what I can do is I can
go at a number of key locations I'm just
going through all of these locations and
I'm looking at what the initial
condition response would look like for
that infinitesimally impulse and I'm
going to add them all up so I'm going to
draw this picture so so at early times U
is equal to zero and so my system
response is just zero here at time where
this step turns on I have a teeny tiny
little impulse response and so I get a
teeny tiny little exponential decay and
here at time you know in the middle of
my response I have another little
impulse response and I got another
little decay at the end of my impulse
response you know may be right at this
point here my system is flat again and
so on and so forth so for every little
point in this control this input
function U I'm saying that it's creating
these infinitesimal impulse responses
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
add all of these up so at x 0 I have 0
response the time you know 0.1 I have
zero response and then when the step
turns on I actually start getting a
little response and those responses add
up until something meaningful happens so
my output response my state X is going
to look like zero and then as the step
starts I'm going to start accumulating
some outputs and then once the step
turns out I'm not going to be
accumulating anything everything else is
just going to die out and so I get my
exponential decay okay this was not a
movie this was me drawing on the board
so I promised you a movie and
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to exactly compute that
convolution integral using this idea so
every little U of tau Delta Tau is going
to give me so I could call this a U of
you know tau 1 Delta Tau impulse
response so I'm going to break this up
into finite rectangles and the area
these are now not infinitesimally
they're just small ok questions before I
actually do this in MATLAB maybe I
should do it in that lab and then take
questions ok
okay good maybe I will just play the
movie first and then I'll write the code
okay so here's the movie
I'm taking my impulse response and I'm
running it through okay let me let me
walk you through this so this is my
function you the input this second panel
here is essentially showing my impulse
response and it's being time shifted
because you know when this step turns on
my impulse / start response starts at
time five and so I want it to be
windowed there so it's moving along as
these red dots move and what I'm doing
is I'm taking this impulse response at
this location in time times U of T delta
T and I'm adding it to my solution so my
solution is just accumulating response
every time I you is nonzero so let me
run this again
so this is my output zero zero zero zero
now it starts accumulating because my u
is on and then once you turns off it
just decays forever okay so this is kind
of pictorially what the convolution is
doing I can give it other inputs it
doesn't have to be a square wave it can
be a sine wave let's say that this is
from minus one point one and that's so
now my input is a sine wave
okay and notice that the output is a
sine wave right we know that the input
and the output of a linear system is
going to be a sine wave to an input sine
wave but the magnitude and the phase are
slightly different we can get those from
the frequency response does anyone want
to see how I actually went through and
wrote this code yeah yes good okay
I was afraid everyone was gonna say no
okay so let's clear all clothes all CL
see this will be the last thing I do
today I'm quite sure
well the last thing I do in this class
today hopefully but there is more in the
notes and I am NOT going to cover them
on Wednesday so if you're interested
read them they're free pages it's
essentially a summary of how this would
generalize to systems of OD ease like X
dot equals a of X a times X and I have a
picture showing how I see physical
systems and I think you'll find it
useful but it's not really anything I'm
gonna examine over okay good so we clear
all closed all CLC I'm gonna create an S
that's a transfer function and lambda
equals 1 and what's the what's my
transfer function for X dot equals
lambda X 1 over S Plus lambda that's
what I would get if I Laplace transform
if I took a 1 over the characteristic
polynomial so my system is 1 divided by
s plus lambda okay now I have to create
did I close the window I did so I have
to create just gonna run this again so I
need to create a vector of time from 0
to 15 that includes my input U and then
I also need to create a vector from time
0 to 2 T to 30 for my convolution okay
so I'm going to make DT equals 0.1 T
equals 15 and my time vector is in
increments of DT up to T U is going to
start out as 0 and I want to make it a
square
where the middle third is the square
wave so U of n divided by 3 to 2 and
divided by 3 is equal to 1 okay middle
third square wave and then I need to do
something I need to I need to get my Y
impulse response my wimp and my timp are
equal to the impulse of my system in
time okay
in puzzle ok we don't have in puzzle we
want to impulse good and then the last
thing is I need to create my solution
vector which is twice as long as my u
vector ok so my solution vector T
solution is DT and increments of DT up
to two big T's X solution starts out
being 0 times T solution just zero
everywhere and I'm gonna keep adding to
it ok so now we need a for loop right
any any questions so far this is just a
set up okay so for k equals 1/2 the
length of my input u my first subplots 3
1
my first subplot I'm just going to plot
the control signal you so I have it up
so plot T by you by in black I'm going
to hold on and I'm gonna plot the
current time that I'm on in a red circle
okay so I'm plotting the whole signal
you in black and then I'm gonna plot the
particular time that I'm on the case
time as a red circle so let's say I just
ended here a test con - okay so this
thing basically just went through for K
equals 1 to 150 and it just went through
and plotted a red circle
you should probably say draw now and
pause 0.05 so that it actually shows
something
okay that's my first thing that I just
did good now in my second subplot
subplot 3 by 2 by 3 by 1 by 2 I'm gonna
plot my impulse response but I'm gonna
keep shifting my impulse response in
time right so I'm gonna plot T imp plus
T of K I'm shifting by T of K this is
like my towel ok
I'm shifting by T of K if I was really
clever I probably would have named one
of these variables tau but I think I
would get confused so one of these
variables is tau the other ones T and
I'm going to plug this in ok ok good and
then the last thing I need to do in my
last subplot I need to actually add up
this impulse response to my solution so
now X solution from K to K minus 1 plus
length of T ok so my solution is this
really long twice the length of 2 vector
and every K I'm stepping forward and I'm
adding up my impulse response to K up to
the length of T this is just a way of
keeping track of the indices so that's
going to equal what it originally
equalled plus my impulse response which
is DT times U of K times my Y impulse
response and I'm transposing it because
it's a column vector and the other one's
a row vector ok this is hard to read
maybe I will make it dot dot like that
so my solution vector at the current
shifted values is equal to my old
solution vector Plus this new DT impulse
response DT times U of K times my
impulse response I think that's actually
it so now you get to plot it subplot
three by one by three plots T solution
by X solution in black
and it's nice to give myself some axes
so that it keeps looking nice okay
anything else nope think this is good
no that didn't work I forgot to put I'm
just plotting time
okay let's plot my why imp good thank
you
now the system turns on starts
accumulating the system turns off and
just keeps decaying okay questions about
how we wrote this or what this this
impulse response means yeah like you
have the T the Tau but you didn't call
anything town how does that keep you
like repeat honey yeah I mean I'm
essentially taking this equation and I'm
literally just taking this impulse
response shifted by tau so so T of K is
my town I should've just call it T of K
tau and then every I'm just taking this
and I'm shifting it to the right by tau
and I'm multiplying it by the the
magnitude of that offense is U of tau
delta tau u U of K DT and I can give any
you I want that's why the convolution is
so powerful that's when the impulse
response of supply okay next time you
use
you